oh well I don't know here's Prague there
it is I mean this is the city of the
alchemist this is old Bohemia on the
brink of the third millennium
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
live-in types of richard lon
[Music]
strolling through
[Music]
nothing
[Music]
all of these places
[Music]
[Music]
in front of that door
[Music]
oh it's it are you on the third floor
this is nice this is a very nice area of
art galleries and smaller right now and
aquarium like here
it's not some night
[Music]
as a gallery
[Music]
all in this gallery this is a really
family operation
[Music]
[Music]
and ensemble power given that you
approach fill the wall
[Music]
this is the things that saw Berlin
France where it stuff fitted with
support they got in the gentlemen they
always hung out at this a little
Cafe and plotted resolute
[Music]
why the building here that you answering
that's me requested in Europe
[Music]
[Music]
come on soos rolling in
Jackie moving
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well I don't know here's Prague there it
is I mean this is the city of The
Alchemist this is old Bohemia on the
brink of the third millennium
this is they call Prague the city of
towers you can really see why from the
16th century onward it looked like this
with these baroque towers piercing the
skyline
this is the neighborhood I would choose
to live in I think right here it's near
and part of everything that these are
quiet streets away from the flow of some
nice little fourth story apartment with
you can steal the appointments that
would be all right I think
so this is Prague on an early Sunday
morning in summer but the calm is
deceptive in this country is on the
brink of falling to pieces it may break
in two while we're here this week
one of the challenges of keeping Prague
beautiful is keeping modern buildings
from interrupting with Scylla otherwise
it'll be Manhattan iced and destroyed
they need to designate Prague one that
sounds unbuildable
[Music]
[Music]
this is a really funny part of town
why is that there would be no reason to
be in this product and that [ __ ] made a
mistake yes
so many positive term that depend on
people making mistake of going there I
guess that's true most parts of towns
are like that
now this is familiar territory
well yes I bet he is I think this is
where
when it's either right or left the place
we come out of the tunnel
yeah that's what we're looking for is
but yeah except you're the town I'm very
visible isn't it right up here that's
right
Nemus
maybe down around that corner but we
should be done up on the hill that the
town
so I think that money comes from the
left there I think we're perfect get
over our I think it's right around this
corner yeah they did see we've got all
these there's the girl in the billboard
and the whole thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
there you go rolling speed
[Music]